die jobs emission könnte den großen
durchbruch bei der suche nach
außerirdischen leben bedeuten denn mit
hilfe des weltraumteleskops das mitte
dezember 2019 ins all befördert wurde
möchten astronomie teams weltweit
endlich das herausfinden was uns bislang
von exoplaneten verborgen blieb den jobs
kann zum ersten mal viel mehr über die
exoplaneten herausfinden und
außerirdischem leben auf die spur kommen
klicks und science und fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ja nichts los geht's
[Musik]
preislich willkommen das ist wirklich
eine neue phase in der forschung nach
außerirdischem leben und es ist schon
ein bisschen verflixt denn obwohl
astronomie teams mittlerweile rund 4000
exo planeten in der milchstraße
aufgespürt haben ist kaum etwas über
diese extrasolaren planeten bekannt
bislang wissen fachleute dass es viele
verschiedene exoplaneten gibt manche mit
wolken aus blausäure andere besitzen
eine kruste aus edelsteinen doch weil
sie so weit weg sind gestaltet sich eine
genaue analyse als äußerst kompliziert
und so gelingt das aufspüren von
exoplaneten und die bestimmung von deren
masse und entfernung zum stern nur
indirekt eine methode besteht
beispielsweise daraus das wackeln von
sternen zu beobachten dass durch die
schwerkraft von exoplaneten bedingt ist
doch ein teleskop mit dessen hilfe man
die größe der extrasolaren planeten
messen kann fehlte bislang und so ist
jobs eine besondere premiere die von
fachleuten weltweit sehnlichst
herbeigewünscht wurde jobs steht für
catering exoplanet satellite also ein
satellit zur beschreibung von
exoplaneten denn jobs kann noch viel
mehr
denn dieses beschreiben ist genau das
ziel es geht also bei dieser mission nur
um einen sehr kleinen teil neue bislang
unentdeckte exo planeten aufzuspüren
sondern die bereits bekannten besser zu
verstehen mehrere hundert sterne in
unserer nachbarschaft um die bereits
planeten entdeckt wurden werden also
ganz besonders im fokus von jobs stehen
möglich werden soll das auch durch ein
sogenanntes photometer in der
fachsprache wird damit ein sehr genaues
messgerät bezeichnet das die stärke von
lichtmess chips soll messen in welchem
ausmaß die helligkeit eines sterns
nachlässt wenn sich ein exoplanet auf
seiner umlaufbahn vor diesen stern
schiebt dadurch werden dann berechnung
möglich die letztendlich die größe des
exoplaneten zum ergebnis haben
doch noch mehr denn mit diesen
informationen und der bereits bekannten
masse kann dann auch auf die dichte
geschlossen werden und das ermöglicht
super spannende einblicke
denn somit lässt sich auch die
zusammensetzung des jeweiligen
exoplaneten nachvollziehen handelt es
sich um einen gasriesen oder einen
gesteinsplaneten und weiß der wickie
sogar riesige ozeane auf forschungsteams
weltweit sind ganz kribbelig vor
aufregung dazu der nobelpreisträger
didier queloz von der universität gent
nach zwei jahrzehnten der planeten
entdeckung treten wir nun in die ära der
exoplaneten kunde ein
denn mit chips können wir nun die
physikalischen und chemischen
eigenschaften von planetensystemen
außerhalb unseres eigenen ergründen
zusätzlich wird es aber auch rund 15
prozent seiner zeit mit der suche nach
dem noch unentdeckten exoplaneten
verbringen optimistisch sind die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
ganz besonders weil man bei teams weiß
wo man hingucken muss das ist ein
riesiger vorteil sein platz wird das
teleskop auf einer sonnen synchron
erdumlaufbahn in 700 kilometern höhe
haben hier würde es dann die exo
planeten beobachten wie sie ihren stern
passieren in der fachsprache ist hier
von trun sitzt die rede doch es wird
nicht bei einem transit bleiben sondern
teams wird gleich mehrere solcher
passagen ins visier nehmen die
veränderung der helligkeit im
sternenlicht können so ganz besonders
präzise vermessen werden und nicht nur
der dran sind der exoplaneten ist für
die forschenden von besonderem interesse
vermessen werden auch die licht kurven
die entstehen wenn die exoplaneten in
ihrem orbit seitlich vom stern stehen
und von diesen beleuchtet werden diese
ergebnisse können infos darüber liefern
ob eine atmosphäre existiert und wie sie
zusammengesetzt ist und das wiederum
gibt hinweise auf mögliches lebens
spannend ist hier auch ob wolken
vorhanden sind ins visier genommen
werden dazu vor allem extrasolare
planeten die eine größe aufweisen die
irgendwo zwischen der größe der erde und
der des neptuns liegen jobs ist ein
projekt der europäischen weltraumagentur
esa und der schweiz gesteuert wird der
satellit von spanien aus der plan sieht
vor dass die mission mindestens
dreieinhalb jahre
dauert aliens oder tote sterne little
white men 1 anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar doktor wissenschaft
sehr sehr cooler kanal und neu bei
unserem kleinen wissenschafts netzwerk
es 1054 bis dann bleibt dran